[موسيقى]
منذ نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي احدث
الاصدار العام لبرنامج
المحادثه الاليه تشات
صدمه في العالم الاكاديمي حيث استخدم
ملايين المرات لم يستغرق الامر وقتا طويلا
حتى اكتشف الطلاب انه يمكن لروبوت
المحادثه المدعوم بالذكاء الصناعي ان يكون
جيدا في القيام بالواجبات المنزليه
والمقررات الدراسيه
يقال ان النسخه الرابعه من منصه
المدعومه بكميات كبيره من البيانات من
الانترنت
اجتازت امتحانات يجريها محامون متدربون في
كليه الحقوق بالولايات المتحده بعد كتابه
مقالات بشان موضوعات تتراوح من القانون
الدستوري الى القانون الجبائي
ومع ذلك فان بعض خبراء التعليم ليسوا
مقتنعين تماما ونبهوا الى ان مخاطر هذه
التكنولوجيا يمكن ان تؤدي الى الغش على
نطاق واسع وحتى الى نهايه طرق التدريس
التقليديه في الفصول الدراسيه فقد اعرب
عدد المدير المدارس البريطانيه في رساله
الى صحيفه
عن تخوفهم من الاثار السلبيه لتقنيات
الذكاء الصناعي الجديده مشيرين الى عدم
ثقتهم باداء الشركات التكنولوجيه وقال
مدير مدارس الدوله والقطاع الخاص ان انظمه
الذكاء الصناعي تتطور بسرعه كبيره جدا لا
تواكبها الفصول الدراسيه ولا تستطيع
الحكومه وحدها تقديم المشوره الكافيه
للمدارس
واعلنوا عن انشاء لجان استشاريه لتقديم
النصح للمدارس بشان المجالات المفيده
مدرتي للذكاء الاصطناعي وستعمل هذه اللجان
لمصلحه الطلاب والمعلمين ولن تخضع لضغوط
عمالقه التكنولوجيا لكن لتكنولوجيا الذكاء
الصناعي مزايا ايضا اذ يمكنها مساعده
المعلمين على وضع العلامات وخطط الدروس
واتاحه الفرصه لهم لقضاء المزيد من الوقت
مع تلاميذهم وفي وقت تحضر فيه بعض المدارس
والجامعات في بلاد اخرى انظمه الذكاء
الصناعي اقر رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
سابقا بان اي محاولات لصياغه تشريعات
المتعلقه بالذكاء الاصطناعي
ستتقادم بسرعه بالنظر الى وتيره التغيير
السريعه